[Musique]
bonsoir les amis pauvre nounours deviner
ce qui lui arrive ce soir ce n'est pas
difficile à deviner
hier soir il a été trop gourmand il a
mangé trop de sucreries et il a mal au
temps plein au bouton et voilà les
gourmands sont toujours punis
je brûle bourg du coloris pop rock aux
frontières ou rool pour trop bien sûr
nos noces mais de fatigue pas bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tant que tu touches revient à situer
nettement futé
tu veux manger quelques jours répète
confiture waouh et au miel d'abeilles
surtout pas supporter que je mangeais
trop de confiture hier soir j'ai pas le
goût
[Musique]
tiens bois pas d'eau mono 7 fera du bien
encore me faire plaisir et tu oublieras
tu es dans nine est au repos oui
d'accord pimprenelle
viens avec nous dans la chambre rose
[Musique]
voilà moi c'est la fin de la journée
c'est le moment de ce congé nous faisons
comme nos amis ils s'en vont tous au lit
non si elles sont aussi sur son nuage
sera maman
le marchand de sable à temps il nous
dira fermez vos yeux et dom et tous les
deux nous sommes bien dans notre lit
nono son fouet la bonne la nuit sa
grosse voix me faisait plaisir à mme
raja vais m'endormir
non je vais m'endormir sa foi nous fait
plaisir
[Musique]
vous avez maintenant tu vas vite aller
coucher comme ça qui sera guérie demain
va vite auto changement subit non pas
qu'ils sont mignons de nuit nous nous à
demain tant bien nicolas annie pas pr
neil
[Musique]
nounours va vite aller faire dodo comme
ça demain il sera guéri à te voilà
grands malades sous culson lui dont ceux
qu son but pour tout boum boum sourd de
jeunes de ne pas trop alors en route
bonne nuit les enfants aller vite au lit
et faites de beaux rêves
bonne nuit pour lui
[Musique]